I don't necessarily know if these products work
and I don't know that I necessarily am using them uh for that
what I do know is being in a shitty relationship has made me cry
a lot more than I ever have in my whole entire life
and you know how like
the president
when you see pictures of like
any sitting president
they show their first day in office and they show their last day in office
that's kinda how I feel
you know five years after divorce
so I buy these products just
even if it's for the placebo effect
even if it's cause I'm like you know
I just need to do something other than cry sometimes
and so not only does that help me stop crying
it makes me kind of feel like I'm doing something
to combat the shit that goes on in my life
so if you want one
the link is right here
I don't know if it works
but I know it makes me feel better
and I bought myself a tiny little treat
there's coupons all the time on TikTok
use the fucking coupon and get it for free
you know what I mean